traza la línea de reflexión que mapear a
el cuadrilátero s
rt si nos referimos a este cuadrilátero
ese o rt este que está aquí en azul en
el otro cuadrilátero de abajo es decir
este que está aquí en gris este que está
aquí
para hacer este ejercicio lo que voy a
utilizar es esta línea esta herramienta
que está aquí y entonces digamos que si
quisiera yo hacerlo aproximando
utilizando mi vista pues podría intentar
digamos podría yo intentar acercarme lo
más posible
pero veamos cómo puedo resolver este
problema observó que si este punto será
reflejado por esta línea entonces el
punto reflejado que es el que está de
este lado tendrá que estar a la misma
distancia de la línea a través de la
cual se reflejan digamos la distancia
que hay de este punto a la línea tendrá
que ser la misma distancia que hay de
este punto a la línea y entonces a ver
veamos si yo pongo este punto en este
lugar y parece que este punto satisface
lo que estoy buscando veamos la
distancia del punto s a este otro punto
y la puedo encontrar sin camino un paso
hacia la izquierda y 3 hacia arriba
llegó del punto s al punto naranja y
ahora del punto naranja al punto
reflejado al que deseo llegar también
puedo llegar
desplazándome un paso a la izquierda y
tres pasos hacia arriba lo mismo que
hice en el anterior definitivamente este
punto es equidistante al punto s y al
punto reflejado hay la misma distancia y
ahora tengo que hacer algo semejante con
este otro punto que define la línea de
reflexión y digamos que voy a escoger un
punto que también este digamos voy a
tomar el punto t y su punto reflejado y
encontrar en un punto sobre la línea que
esté a la misma distancia y este parece
ser un buen candidato a ver observemos
de este punto al punto t camino
un paso a la izquierda y tres pasos
hacia arriba y del punto reflejado para
llegar al punto naranja y me tengo que
desplazar un paso a la izquierda y tres
pasos hacia arriba efectivamente este
punto está a la misma distancia del
punto t que del punto reflejado
y entonces ya tengo una línea de
reflexión basta con tener dos puntos
para definir una línea a través de la
cual el cuadrilátero ese o rt se refleja
en el cuadrilátero de abajo que veamos
la respuesta parece que ya la tengo y
efectivamente lo tengo